it's time for screen junkies movie bytes
Oh what in the world its movie fights
what's going on guys I am all about
today's fight it is exciting
we've got combatants who are ready to
throw down you know what let's dive
right in first oh you know this guy he
is movie manse he is the king of movie
release States as your father yes he's
my biological father Scott man so over
the party pal thanks so much it's so
good to be here with this extremely
great-looking group of panelists and
most clearly you get your good looks
from your father the apple doesn't fall
far from the tree sitting next to Scott
manse oh we're all about that a hashtag
fight life over here from the Schmo down
and pencils and parsecs on Piper RPG
please welcome Emma fine thanks for
having me today
it's great to be here and you know Scott
manse told me before this fight that you
know every other day he is but today he
is not fight for life so every there's
gonna be a fight you know what fight for
life friendships are torn asunder
brothers and sisters facing off we have
one more combatant sitting next to Emma
he's the host of only stupid the only
stupid answers podcast welcome back to
the party DJ betrayed me thanks for
having me horse horse
so we're gonna get into a little
infinity war action there's gonna be
just blossom man lots of fun great
questions and those questions these
battles will be decided by myself and
our two other judges that are right over
there on the Dan cam Dan Moreau hold it
down how's it going Dan are you ready to
get factual I'm always ready to get
facts yeah thanks
actual response dan you will be you are
one of our judges you'll be weighing in
with your opinion based on what based on
the facts how I listen to the arguments
I process them I've read out the BS and
then make the call thank you sir
arguments in facts come out damn right
there we have the Internet's sweetheart
Danielle Danielle so you are a conduit
for the people what you tell us how that
works I am I am you so the way if this
works is that for the first three rounds
we are going to have a pull there are a
really fun fan pulls on Twitter those
ain't our polls those are on YouTube and
if you want to know how they work go
down hit hit the description expand it
will tell you everything you need to
know but also know that we do not put
the polls up until every fighter has
given their answer because we don't want
people picking before they've heard the
arguments based on the arguments not the
picked nope the arguments based on the
ability to debate and so we come into
play if there's a tie or if both of
these lovely gentlemen pick someone
different and we need someone to come in
that's our job that's when we come and
I'll still be checking in just so we can
see your opinion on the fights even if
it doesn't count as an official vote I
will also be checking for all sick and
dank memes last week we can also add
puppets
friends so they're not puppets they
don't like that term
yes yeah you really took an affinity it
took a real liking to those puppets yeah
I mean yeah like I've never seen someone
not since Scott man so lala land
so much a cup for me ladies and
gentlemen
mama when my son brought it up yes or
thankfully this movie fight will
probably be lala land free and this is a
best-of-seven contest the first player
to get four correct aunt for answers
awarded to them four points wins the day
there are three regular round questions
and four speed round questions if after
three questions we are tied one-one one
oh we got sty breakers don't worry
so combatants are you ready ready rock
and roll JT e dropped that sick ass
package
[Music]
[Applause]
jte your package is sick a-a-alright oh
I mean this is a doozy question right
off the bat I'm you know let's save this
question for third okay okay here is
dick what a good question damn now that
we've all seen the movie what character
is the infinity war MVP who's the most
valuable player of the Avengers infinity
war and Scott mance you are sitting
right here to my left you were going
first okay clearly the MVP of Avengers
infinity war the 19th movie in the MCU
the 19th straight number one opening for
the MCU perfect way to celebrate the
10th anniversary of the MCU that started
with Ironman back in May of 2008 movie
release dates the MVP here is not
Ironman the MVP is dr. Stephen strange
played by Benedict Cumberbatch and
here's why first of all Benedict
Cumberbatch seemed to have more fun and
was more confident playing Doctor
Strange in infinity war than he was in
his own movie you could tell that he was
more comfortable that he he got the role
that he was having more fun with it but
with all these characters in Avengers
infinity war you got the Avengers he got
spider-man you got the guardians of the
galaxy he got everyone except the x-men
and the Fantastic Four yet that could
change but dr. Stephen strange he his
confidence was infectious
he stole the show even from Robert
Downey jr. 'he's Iron Man who always I
mean he's like the king of marvel and
and Benedict Cumberbatch just he was
badass
he pulled rabbits out of his hat he had
his magical powers his mystical powers
seem to be more effective and more
powerful than any might that any of the
Avengers had whether it was Thor whether
it was Iron Man himself he had a few
surprises with his cloak and I'd seen
near the end to spoiler alert I mean if
you didn't see the movie you should
listen tennis by the one move forward
here spoilers here but when he
multiplied himself with his arms and
even and all the different I and all the
different doctor Strange's like here's a
movie that is full of actions full of
special effects and everybody was blown
away by that moment alright and Scott
man says Doctor Strange by the way watch
out for someone if they tell you they
have a surprise for you in their cloak
Emma alright listen I see what you're
saying with Doctor Strange as far as the
Avengers go
but the real star and the MVP of the
movie infinity war is clearly fan OHS
the movie is about Thanos it's about his
quest to collect all of the Infinity
stones which he does he is the only
character who 100% accomplishes the goal
that he actually set out to do at the
beginning of the film on top of that we
all know that Marvel kinda has a villain
problem a lot of the times they're
villains are kind of like hulking
lifeless shells they're sort of
disembodied forces of evil and this was
not the case with Panos and this is a
credit to the Russo brothers and their
ability to make you really understand
every single characters point of view if
you look at fan oohs in this film
watching it it is very clear that from
his perspective Thanos is the hero of
his story and the Avengers are the
antagonists towards him which is a huge
feat to pull off with any villain I'm
not saying that it makes him sympathetic
by any means he's still totally crazy
but again you understand his thinking it
is cold hard logic but yeah he came from
a planet that let itself get destroyed
by being overpopulated so logically it
does it make sense to wipe out half of
the population therefore you double your
resources and increase your chance of
survival so from my perspective the
movie is really about Thanos and Thanos
is the one who ultimately emerges
victorious at the end of infinity or ooh
big spoiler
I'm going with pert with everybody if
you wanted to see it you've seen it
alright DJ let's hear from you I think
we can all agree that Avengers infinity
war is a fantastic adventure right it is
full of fun and excitement
it's got interesting themes it's got
interesting characters however because
it has so much of everything one area
that it cuts some corners that it
doesn't really quite none none of the
characters really have a character arc
they don't start one way in a different
person they don't they haven't grown
they may have they may have learned some
stuff but they haven't grown except for
one one character achieves that honor in
this movie and that is team Groot
he starts off the movie just kind of an
annoying teenager obsessed with his
video game not really paying attention
anything around him and through his
adventures with Thor with rocket he
learns the the value of self-sacrifice
the value of taking on responsibility
and he's in the fight with everybody at
the end I think Doctor Strange has some
great fantastic moments and it
definitely is fan of Thanos is the
central character if anybody but these
characters don't change by the end of
the movie the events may change them in
Avengers 4
some more than others but group is the
one character in this movie that I feel
confident I can say has an arc in this
movie changes throughout this movie is a
different character by the end of the
movie
alright one vote for team Groot right
there folks fight it out okay fighting
it out here first of all okay yeah I
mean it's easy to say Thanos is the MVP
because he's the villain really it's
because he is the villain strike one
that does not make him an MVP strike two
is that he's a major character such a
major character that as much as I
thought that Josh Brolin was was very
good
he didn't surprise me he was what I
expected a badass villain who had the
light and the personality to take on the
Avengers right and for the movie to end
the way it did it didn't surprise me
I did not expect Doctor Strange a
character from like the face to hang on
from phase two or phase four yeah I lost
track of
I did not expect dr. strange to steal
the movie to take the biggest chance of
all to save Iron Man like by giving
Thanos theater the time starring any
sense it made a lot of sense he took a
risk he took a risk and maybe he chanced
wrong right maybe he transferred cuz he
can't see the future he could see a lot
more than everyone else can see
he was the standout here and baby what
is it I lost track and I think we could
say man group by the end he takes on
Thor's hammer he hopes their gain his
hammer he joins the fight because again
Doctor Strange is great but he's a
glorified light show sure again disagree
and and Anthea knows he knows the theme
of the movie is couched in what's going
on with him but he doesn't he wants
something he struggles to get it he gets
it that that's a plotline that's not a
character but but I disagree with you
because I think within us and first of
all I wanted to bring up Scott you were
not surprised
that Black Panther and spider-man like
vanished into nothingness at the end of
this movie really wasn't that wasn't
permit from a character trait or a
character in fan s's arc it was what all
the other thing that had to do with
Stannis was accepted no I see I disagree
because I think that Thanos was
presented in such a way in the beginning
of the film that you were kind of led to
believe this is just intergalactic
badass has no feelings going to just
destroy everything without any
consideration for any human life at all
and then that scene with him and
Gomorrah and the soul stone again what
you're getting into okay so first of all
mercilessly kills Loki at the beginning
of the film that just stuck me right in
the heart and that was a bull and that's
the thing is I understand that yes we're
gonna have an infinity War part two but
in terms of this being a first part of a
film it took a lot of big risk and risks
and it did a lot of that through Thanos
through killing off half of the
characters at the end of the film and
particularly that scene with him and
Gomorrah in some ways if spoilers
gomorrah comes back in the next film it
almost cheapens that really emotional
moment that the two of them have she
thinks that she has the upper hand and
going into it you truly believe
that she's right III went into it
thinking he doesn't care about anything
and then they share that look in that
moment of realization
whether it's character development or
not it's certainly a huge revelation
that has insane repetition
yeah it's revelation to the audience but
it's not it's not revelation to Thanos I
don't think I've changed from the events
but let's go back to you talking about
to your point about Thanos being
predictable and your point about Groot
having a character arc that is the
character arc of every teenage character
that is a good teenage character in a
film is it starts off with that I am a
teenager I just want to play my video
games and be alone and not help anybody
out and then they learn through their
interactions with others and seeing the
Herald so is it you're saying it's it's
worse to have a character arc that we've
seen before than having no character arc
at all I'm just no I'm saying that that
just just to Scott's point about things
being predictable I would agree if if
Groot had some huge revelation character
but that's again again it's an argument
of we're arguing about a film that has
three third acts frankly it was cute
group was cute you know everybody loves
to see the Groot okay fine but that
doesn't make him an MVP she wasn't a
standout enough character central enough
to the stakes and the plot and the the
end result of the film to stand out as
an MVP what Doctor Strange did by giving
Thanos back the stone to save Iron Man I
was like why did you do that yeah I mean
because he took a risk he took a chance
she's a stake in the movie I dr. strange
a stake in the film was bigger than
anyone else's stake because of the end
result of what happened wait okay off to
that point he was funny he was confident
he displayed powers okay we have not yet
seen before Scott go ahead and make
these your final thoughts and in the end
you know when you get to the end of
filming he multiplies himself the way he
did you know this is a film where you
could have had battle damaged by the
Anthony movie people are still blown
away dr. strange stole this movie even
from Ironman and that makes him the MVP
of Avengers infinity working
I understand Scott what you're saying in
terms of the importance of dr. strange
in this movie in him giving the time
stone to Thanos
however that ultimately makes him the
MVP of Avengers infinity War part two
because he's the one who ensured that
that happened but that is not the
question we're dealing with we're
looking at who is the MVP of the movie
infinity war that we saw and it is
absolutely fan of his film because he is
the person who set out to accomplish
what he had established to do at the
beginning of the film got the gauntlet
get all the Infinity stones once I have
it I have the power to snap my fingers
make half the population go away I mean
he does it Thanos wins that was a salt
snap by the way I think it feels like
what we're arguing here is the most
important cog or gear in a clock like
this one is the one that makes the gears
move the best and that's that's plot
that's not character a character should
be something that grows and evolves and
changes and these characters have grown
involved and changed a lot over the
these 19 movies but not a lot in this
movie even Thanos because again he wants
something and he gets the thing and with
group we have a carrot that's what
that's what makes him not just a
character but the MVP because he
actually grows and changes unlike any
other character Thank You DJ and that is
time Wow
oh stuff there a lot of good stuff Dan
Moreau what's going on with the facts
pretty factually sound I mean a very
opinion based I didn't say anything that
really contradicted events in the movie
so but very much just me listening and
trying to formulate these arguments
because there were three very strong
arguments absolutely absolutely
yeah this was quite a throwdown each
three very different characters from the
movie you know what I'll say it right
now third place goes to DJ Groot I
couldn't your specific definition of the
character that changed the most makes
him the MVP that didn't quite compute
for me and I think Scott said it and in
the close to the end that he didn't
factor enough into the overall film that
being said you made me appreciate teen
group just a little bit more I can't
call him the MVP the and more so than
the talk it's just like who drives the
movie
I think MVP so came down to these two
for me and this you know I don't even
want to choose because we both really
three down but sigh I didn't there were
a lot of tape downs attempted at Emma
but I feel like sheath warded them the
same way that O's tried to thwart all
the takedowns
of him in the movie the villain can't be
the MVP who says no surprise who cares
it's who drove the movie and I think
Emma really nailed the points of solving
the villain problem his story coming to
fruition and she won me over
Emma gets the point very difficult I
have to agree I'm sorry if it has the
best arc in the movie then I think DJ
had a very strong are you yes we're
talking MVP I had to eliminate DJ yeah
it also came down to me between Emma and
Scott and your writings are two very
very tough arguments to differentiate
force between for me it came down to
looking at the question MVP the most
valuable player of infinity war and even
then you know they both made such great
cases I think just barely I think it
might have been Scott for me just
because he made the point of the fact
that he exceeded the expectation from
his own movie the role that he played
and the overall conflict as well that he
out shown other characters that were on
the screen it's literally like 50/50 for
me if I could give you both the point
I'm gonna tilt ever so slightly towards
Scott because these are two great
arguments it's really tough to choose
but I can't befall you for that it's
fitting that comes down to the fans to
decide Danielle
alrighty well looking at the polls there
is a very clear winner we have got
Thanos at 54% with Doctor Strange at 35%
and team Groot at 9% which I do want to
say that character arc argument that was
a good one [ __ ] hey I liked it we can't
all pick Thanos
or any other fun answers from the peanut
gallery um there were first of all the
people are loving your four horsemen
shirt where aren't Anderson tell you
what ya know nobody loved in the Beatle
shirt people everyone expects the Beatle
shirt no one expects four horsemen for
question number one we immediately got
buster bluth or no Buster Bluth we got
our Tobias bouquet apparently is in the
background yeah the scene when they're
in the collector yes if you're looking
for the part where it says like you know
uh Arrested Development characters
courtesy of blah blah blah Buster why I
keep saying buster I'm Thomas few and K
is in the background blue and so someone
picked him sneaking up on fantasies
behind Gamora yeah so thank you fast 817
Co n o our cave three one two says the
true and VP infinity war is Wong shows
up kids wet and gets to chill for the
rest of the movie on a couch okay they
just steal your most valuable thing yeah
but I gotta there's too many people here
already I'm cars and half of his brain
I'm out of here
good first battle Emma you take the
point for tuning ball Bruce Willis
alright here we go oh boy we got an
exciting a new trailer for Mamma Mia to
you guys do trailer breakdowns of the
Mamma Mia trailer you know what I I
skipped that one know what band should
have its music turned into a big movie
musical what band should have its music
turned into a big movie musical and
question two we'll start with player two
Emma five okay so when it comes down to
you're making a big movie musical you
kind of have two options and one is to
go the high-concept route and the other
is to go more the the sing street route
the play
in journey we're actually creating music
it doesn't even necessarily have to be
creating music and there is one band
with whom you could absolutely do either
one of those things and that is Duran
Duran they have such a great collection
of really fun catchy high-energy songs
that have lyrics that are just vague and
confusing enough that you can apply them
to whatever sort of life situation you
need to create again you can go I think
either with the sort of high concept
musical rap because my goodness guys
have you have seen that music video for
wild boys like that is a movie unto
itself that's an a5 I want to see a
movie that just explains what the f is
going on in weird Mad Max drag queen
beautiful disaster that like I am here
for but again the other option is to go
more of that it's almost like a sing
Street meets what they did with Chicago
kind of concept of it's somebody who's
like going through their own sort of
mundane life you know you get a little
ordinary world action in there but
within their life any sort of struggles
that they're trying to overcome you get
to go into these you know more like
fantasy musical sequences where you
really dig into the the really like pop
punk like synth 80s kind of stuff that
Duran Duran has going on and again it's
another one of those bands that I mean
we see a little bit across the universe
that it's so nice to like transpose some
songs were originally intended for men
for women particularly when men do have
these higher voices and you get some
really fresh interesting takes on
material that people already know and
love all right very cool and for the
record my go-to karaoke song is hungry
like the DJ so musicals are a beautiful
film genre that is kind of like fallen
to the wayside in recent years so if
you're gonna bring it back you want to
do something that I was gonna interest
audience that maybe is something a
little bit different than they're used
to but it's stuff that they're listening
to and that they care about and also as
a cinematic quality to it so for me when
I was thinking about those I was
thinking about Arcade Fire who actually
really did do the score for the movie
her which is a fantastic film score and
they're their songs tell stories their
songs have they they have a sweeping
feel to them they have it feels
cinematic and it would be it would bring
something interesting to the
physical genre that might get people
that have already shut that door in
their brain to go check out a musical
and it could be anything and everything
it could be an old Western it could be a
few of films that in the future like her
was it gives you a lot of different
options for telling a story alright DJ
with Arcade Fire
Scott man's background to you okay now
now I'm just gonna say for the record
yes I was going to choose the Beatles
because they are my go-to band for
everything but it's been done across the
universe so that's why I'm just wearing
the shirt in honor of the question but
my go-to bands for a musical is
Fleetwood Mac and here's the beauty of
it the story has already been written
because it really happened you have war
you have a movie musical sent around the
making of Fleetwood Mac's classic
timeless groundbreaking big selling
album rumours and here's why the story's
already been written because during the
making of that album in the making of
that album rumours
you had Christine McVie and John McVie
we're breaking up where they even broke
up by that point and that you have
Stevie Nicks and Lindsey Buckingham who
were breaking up by that point oh and
also you have Stevie Nicks and mcflip
would having an affair so you have a
movie that is that is sex
it is they threw at doing a lot of drugs
a lot of cocaine so there's a lot of
drugs and rock and roll because with
classic songs like go your own way I
don't want to know dreams and then other
songs like landslide over my head hold
me in gypsy these are songs that reflect
what these people were actually going
through and I even have to cast already
picked out Lindsey Buckingham played by
Bradley Cooper keep going but uh anyone
can chime in now Lindsey Buckingham
played by Bradley Cooper mick fleetwood
army flipped with mick fleetwood played
by Christian Bale John McVie played by
Paul Giamatti Christine McVie played by
Jennifer Lawrence and Steve is a little
bit
what was what was that freaking movie
that the Christian Bale and Jennifer
Lawrence Amy Adams why many of them sing
yes okay here's the thing
again I think we you need something
that's gonna DS are these are great
bands these are fantastic bands I think
you need something that would shake up
the formula what people expect
especially if you're looking at like a
biopic following a band that's a very
sturdy formula but it's also a little
bit creaky we've seen it used before
it's it's it allows a lot of
opportunities just to fall to kind of
get lazy with it sure and do what we've
all seen before and I think doing
something kind of new or a little bit
fresh or something that people are still
just discovering like Arcade Fire
affords you an opportunity to make a
film that challenges you to do more with
the musicals but I also think that you
know circling back to my choice of Duran
Duran there is this very strong kind of
80s nostalgia that's going on and I
think that that can transpose really
well into honestly and I'm not even
saying it's not what we expect from a
big movie musical it is but that's
that's the beauty of the big movie
musical is you want something that is a
little expected that's over-the-top and
in this not only are you harkening back
to the idea of the movie musical but
you're also tapping into that 80s
nostalgia which is why I think that this
is something that would definitely be
appealing to studios here a little bit I
want to hear a little bit from you guys
on what your movie would look like I
understand the style and a little bit of
the flavor of it but I wouldn't mind
hearing a little bit more because can I
anyone can do
this was an arcade fire great bands love
their music but you know what I don't
see Arcade Fire as being timeless like
30 years from now I don't think the
people are gonna be like yeah man Arcade
Fire I mean there might be a little and
Duran Duran I look I was born in 68 I
grew up with Duran Duran I love Duran
Duran but there is a nostalgic factor to
Duran Duran Church makes them a little
too nice there's a nostalgic factor to
the idea of a movie music lot but
Fleetwood Mac the music is timeless it's
not dated it's not nostalgic it is
timeless this is music that everyone
even you know 30 40 years ago this album
came out people still know the songs
whether they are older in their 70s and
80s or younger in their teens in their
20s everybody knows the songs of rumors
and that is why a movie based on the
music of Fleetwood Mac centered around
rumors would be grounded it would appeal
to everyone it will be on Broadway
forever and it will be a box-office
listen to that you know what you are and
listen the the making of rumours is a
very interesting story this is very much
rooted in a period piece the thing that
would be about you know how you said you
want to hear more about what I wanted
this to be so with yeah again it's like
you can go one of two ways but like
honestly you in my brain this is an
over-the-top glitzy post-apocalyptic Mad
Max style musical and this is basically
doing right by it so basically there was
a there's a musical called we will Rocky
which is the music of Queen it's only a
stage show but they kind of screwed it
up so here you have an opportunity with
another band that's got like really fun
catchy over the top kind of things and
you have a chance to do it right on top
of that I don't know if you guys are
familiar with the musical dance of the
vampires and you know it is an Austrian
musical for the record I am NOT poser
Jim Stein
bro total eclipse of the heart so
basically the sort of concept of that is
you watch that total eclipse of the
heart music video you're like I don't
know what's going on there in a weird
castle
they took it a step further they're like
you know what we're just gonna make this
crazy vampire musical and it totally
works so it is a formula that is
possible to do what do you think I think
if you're doing Arcade Fire a lot of
arcade music has been associated with
Spike Jones films specifically like I
said her and I think something in that
tone and that style I think would really
interest people and engage people in a
way that like if you're not I think if
you heard Duran Duran musical it that
you're going whether you go or not
completely depends on whether you're
Duran Duran or Fleetwood Mac whereas
Arcade Fire might compel people that
would normally shut down a musical or
don't they don't necessarily need the
association of nostalgia it's based on
the the music that because even though
the music's great don't like your and
ran oh your enemy-and and you could do
stuff that is challenging with the music
that that classic songs that that
already have it's that the people those
songs is already kind of set in stone
time alright
time time time let's go to Dan we're on
the facts and then Dan why don't you
stick around and give us your thoughts
matches yeah released in February 1977
which makes it just over 41 years old
hold me which is one of the songs that
Scott mentioned was written and released
after rumors so officially disqualified
and I just I love it it's kind of like
how I feel with the movies of my
generation which is like that's dated
but mine will last forever like Arcade
Fire won't last but Fleetwood Mac is
time everything that they liked is
exactly for me so many things as you all
tell me on a daily I hate to say it
again but for me this was between Scott
and Emma
choice I love Arcade Fire but you kept
referring how it was used in other
movies but I still never really got a
handle on how you would use it in your
movie so it was between for me Scott and
Emma and I felt that Emma painted a much
clearer portrait of what her movie was
going to be what the tone of it would be
I had a good idea of it and it was just
more appealing to me than kind of a
biopic set to music so my vote goes to
Emma
ding Duran Duran me thanks Dan yeah I
felt III see your logic there but I in
between Emma and Scott and DJ I mean I
love the newer take on the movie musical
but I didn't quite see the movie come
together and you started to really fill
out the world but I thought Scott had
the clearer picture of what his film
would be and it's not my favorite of
Fleetwood Mac is my least favorite of
these three bands
Scott Scott won me over with the
clearest vision you're really sorry to
come through at the end there and if you
made it about a maniac wolf yeah and
then you would have just been like and
if you and if you were also if you had
referenced the lyrics I smell like a
sound sure it's big enough that it's
applicable to many situations but yeah
that being said gotta go Scott man so
you're tied again Daniel Radford
alrighty checking the poll right this
instant
another clear winner with Fleetwood Mac
at 60%
five percent an arcade fire at 12% sure
I thought I would have had the kids with
that one I don't know what the kids are
doing the kids are trapping yes a Donald
Glover but the question was very
specifically banned yeah so I didn't
want to get deep for that I where there
were some other answers they threw out
their answers that we got was a lot of
people came out for they might be giants
and then we have one really fun one
someone wrote at Bruce Kris not Ruth
Chris Bruce Chris Rose ha ha and at
movie manses unabashedly pitching
cocaine the musical don't stop taking
about two and other hits I don't know
maybe it's just me cuz I love old-school
hip-hop but I thought Public Enemy might
be really just like unique and fun and
just and like wild and vibrant and a
little political and crazy
I wanted to see The Black Parade a
couple musical okay yeah I think you are
okay no question okay
Comcast Universal is making a play to
undercut Disney and by Fox pitch a movie
that crosses over at least one Fox and
one universal franchise I'm excited
DJ what's your guy I was a little
worried with this one at first because
you know you notice you're not right off
the top of your head it's harder to just
rattle off some Universal Fox franchises
but as I looked into it I think I think
there a clear a clear pattern emergent
and I was hard pressed to find a better
movie combination than if you could
combine maybe dinosaurs with like
zombies and maybe aliens wait that's my
comic caster calm calm
[Applause]
beautiful is what's our more about that
later yes is if you I thought it'd be
really interesting if you crossed the
Planet of the Apes with Jurassic Park
imagine the world why all the Apes
post-apocalyptic humans are basically
wiped out Apes rule the world
they're colonizing they're spreading out
and they come to an island what's on
that island
oh no the humans were genetically
experimenting on creating dinosaurs
along with the Apes so now the Apes have
to deal with prehistoric monsters as
their antagonists as opposed to humans
ma'am that's fun okay up next
backgrounds got mance I see your planet
eh
and I raised you okay because I'm not
just gonna take two recent film
franchises to put together no that's not
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna take one of
the best film franchise it hasn't been
around since 1989 I'd go to what if you
had a movie called back to the future of
the Planet of the Apes Wow and in this
movie these two eight three thousand
years into the future named doc and
Marty take a an ape style DeLorean time
machine that goes 80 miles per hour
wait so dr. Marty rapes awesome time
they go back in time to the 20th century
to see the evolution they go back in
time to see their Jesus their Caesar
become the first talking but in doing so
in doing so their Directorate their
disguises cop with a mask you can see
their faces no no this is this could
work and it would be a great story
because by going back in time to observe
the creation of the Apes they get they
get messed up as they mess up the doctor
you know James Franco's plans lasted he
gets arrested so now he's not going to
be able to create the the serum that is
going to make Caesar the first talking
eight so now the entire future all right
guys they won't exist at all they have
to break break him out of jail and they
have to get him to create the serum that
is going to inject Caesar with the serum
that will create the plan to use
so their future will be restored and
there at the rate the speech will D
dominant and and it's it literally is
back to the future beats playing it
quiet easy alright I can't wait to hear
a Caesar gets hit on by his own mom high
fantasy concept Back to the Future
Planet of the Apes Jurassic Park kind of
things yeah now let me tell you about my
movie drive fast and live furiously of
course die hard and fast and the furious
where you just put all the best badasses
in the same movie everyone wants a
team-up of Dominic Toretto and John
McClane and logically it makes a lot of
sense because where did we leave Dominic
Toretto
at the end of fate of the Furious it was
a whole hullabaloo in Russia where was
John McClane last time we saw him pretty
similar situation and ultimately it
ended with both of them reconnecting
with their children these are two
franchises well I mean in Don's case
reconnecting with a baby as much as you
possibly can but with with John McClane
I was reconnecting with Lucy and Jack
which was really important because we
were introduced to them in the first
film so John McClane has been on this
journey to like discover the meaning of
family and what are the Fast and the
Furious films about family they drive
home that message really really strong
so this is a movie that's going to start
somewhere out on the East Coast and in
it we're going to have John McClane and
doctor Etta finally encounter one
another probably circa New York City
there's going to be some like crazy drug
cartel and terrorists action involved
and it's a family road trip movie to get
John McClane back to where it all began
in LA to reconnect finally with this
freaking wife where we haven't seen for
three goddamn films
one with you you're gonna get rights in
the streets from back my future fans
that don't want their franchise ruined
also Planet apes has has rewound on its
own time or at least twice now our
franchise so and we've already seen it
in Rise of the Planet ape so we don't
need to go back is just just to kind of
circle back and piggyback off of that DJ
in terms of what you're saying is I like
your idea Scott I like it very much as a
movie however that's not really a
crossover that is a reimagining of
absolutely can we go back to the future
as Planet of the Apes a perfect
crossover because it fits perfectly
you're not meshing them you're making
one movie out of both franchises you
just supported my argument it's not and
here's a day not a crossover if your
movie listen that sounds awesome apes
and dinosaurs together graphic you know
what I'm gonna get after the first like
30 minutes I'm gonna get battle fatigue
yeah it's your actual story there's no
heart
there's no feels there's no humor you're
going to be watching a video game oh
yeah it's gonna be it's gonna be the
same kind of situation that we
encountered in the first minute of
Jackson and here and here is my thing
that is exactly why you should not cross
over Planet of the Apes with Jurassic
Park because Planet of the Apes has
reached this incredible apex as you say
they've reset their timeline a few times
they finally figured it out
Jurassic Park the reason that those
movies have gotten worse and worse as we
going on is because it's gotten away
from what those movies are about which
is humans going too far but humans keep
going too far and making the same
friggin mistake this is about humans
going to for the humans going too far in
two different movies colliding the only
franchises here that you have
permutations in there they they're not
the one story there's multiple versions
of the Jurassic Park sorry there's
multiple versions of Planet apes story
so people would enjoy getting them
together one of the issues with yours
with die hard and fast and furious is
your to make a good fast and furious
movie you're gonna make one of the worst
die hard movies because the bigger
bolder crazy of the action gets an
entire movie the further it gets away
from the first I heard the less
interesting John McClane is but that's
exactly what makes the Fast and Furious
movies great is when they go bigger and
crazier so you're gonna have
a bat fast and furious movie or a bad
die hard movie very clearly
I disagree there's many but you beat me
- now here's the thing okay now now who
your idea of listen that sounds awesome
and it's expected your idea I like I
don't see them I don't see them working
see panty Apes was a chi travel story
the original penny it was a time travel
story he goes 2,000 years into the
future he's really on earth the whole
time you're bringing in the time element
back because the last three films which
are all brilliant the last three Apes
movies it's like the greatest film
trilogy of all time co-star all great so
now you have a chance to mesh playing
Apes with the time travel story which is
where it all started hang on and you're
gonna have a fish out of water story
with the Apes in the 21 you're gonna
have a lot of heart because of the
friendship between doc and Marty and if
you think the Apes the games movies have
always been about how you're kind of
rooting for the Apes and here you are
you have a chance to set the future
right by having the humans dominant and
it's never existing but you want doc and
Marty succeed because you want there to
be a Planet of the Apes but again it's
still a Rick and Morty episode like the
doc and Marty of this are a different
doc and Marty than we now Ettore
allegory the best allegories are the
movie stuck make you really think on the
surface it seems kind of like well
that's it that's okay funny and and can
may be silly but wait a minute there's
actually something here why am what we
have a chance to like set things right
and happy it's not be dominant but you
know what mate I'm rooting for the Apes
to win I want Dawkins you take away the
danger of Jurassic Park in the interest
of Planet the Apes when you take the
human beings out of it again I am I am
coming at two franchises here both of
which in their most recent installments
have definitely not been their best so
here you have an opportunity to kind of
have them meet somewhere in the middle
which ultimately is going to boost both
franchises
these are Maurice are always the best
parts of those movies there's deep
humanity in them whenever the humans
come on they're always an add-on this is
an opportunity to see capes
like that deal with the threat that they
have it faced before and who won
wouldn't want to see a character like
Kobo writing a t-rex and having Caesar
house cool but there's no you're not
good there's not gonna be any by taking
the humans out of it so much of what's
good about the Planet of the Apes movies
is this relationship between the humans
and the Apes and the human actually I
would argue all three of the most recent
final movies would be better if you took
the humans out and just focused on the
Apes that's where the humanity lies in
those movies I agree listen the dawn of
the point of the Apes is the best of the
series only by a threat because like I
said they're all great but again you
you're taking but with the Back to the
Future element you're bringing in the
heart and the humor and by the print of
the Apes element you have a jailbreak
you have it it's a race against time for
them to restore like you want the Apes
to succeed in all three films you were
rooting for the Yates
all right left it listen I understand
great high concept fun if you take two
movies that are purely about basically
superheroes from whom you don't have to
buy any unbelievable backstory just
badass humans who are capable of
incredible feats you're putting them
together you have two movies that are
going to you two franchises that have
struggled a little bit in there later in
their latest installments and then
you're matching them together and on top
of that you are now adding to die hard
again a little bit of some much-needed
diversity that we see in the Fast and
the Furious films and you are having two
characters meet somewhere in the middle
who can learn from each other you have
John McClane who can learn from Don
Toretto's feelings about family and also
Don Toretto able to learn from John
McClane like as sort of a warning of
like hey don't screw things up you got
it going yeah but that is that is the
journey that is the journey is to get
them to meet in the middle
the beauty of a crossover is to see
things that you love interact in an
interesting way and I think the ones
that would be the most interesting for
audiences these would be seeing
something like Jurassic Park and planet
behaves and I think the argument that
there wouldn't be humanity there sounds
like it will be coming from people that
haven't seen the most recent time time
time all right
dan Merle what's going on with the
sexualities again mainly factual I can't
fact-check monkey Rick and Morty great
Rick and Marty episode great movie yeah
once again really just listening to each
argument and making up my mind which I
believe I have although I changed it
many times right on okay so yeah Scott I
feel like they they they knocked you out
with the Rick and Morty stuff this feels
like a Rick like these characters just
in a different dimension and you know
quite frankly uh you didn't you didn't
tell me and I didn't care for your idea
can't be good I like we're friends us
Austin stay weird okay but so came down
to a DJ and Emma for me I'm finally oh
by the way you gave us the
understatement of the year when you said
the last die hard franchise made French
I struggled a lot and you cut the
remembering was in Russia yeah but you
you posed a compelling story and you
made it you connected Bruce Willis to
those other characters and you didn't
even mention that he shares the trait of
baldness with the entire cast various
but DJ presented a strong argument and
there he was right there is some sort of
connective tissue that connects us to
these Apes and what they do in those
films that makes them compelling
characters so the lack of humanity I
felt was properly defended by DJ and he
painted a picture of an action-packed
fun ride so I'm going with DJ
dan Merle you know I was never seriously
considering Scott's idea somehow managed
to retro actively kill both of those for
me so it was between Emma and easy for
me and you know I was leaning toward
Emma and then DJ said something that
really reframed my opinion was when he
said diehard said it's best when it's
gritty and real and a complaints about
that have been that was too cartoonish
and faster the curious is that it's best
when it's cartoonish and it was worse it
was pretty and real and if you do if you
combine these two you're gonna get a bad
movie for either one of those franchises
because they don't mesh and I thought
that was a great point I thought that he
fought back against Scott saying that
the Apes were the most human bet and
part of those new movies and you could
take the humans out and you would have
even more humanity in it strangely for
me the least ridiculous most grounded
option was the talking apes meeting the
dinosaurs and I'm also gone with DJ one
thing if doc and Marty don'ts don't set
the timeline right the Apes are never
gonna be on the ion that is actually you
know what that helps us out sorry Scott
that DeLorean will never fly Danielle
what's uh what's everybody saying okay
well for one thing we did get some great
dank memes they almost immediately made
the Caesar on a raptor yes almost
immediately and it is as beautiful as
you would like us we like we also got
someone saying imagine Dom stumbling
across an alien hive and saying it looks
like a family those were some of the few
a quick taste of some of the dank memes
that we got but the audience poll they
were firmly firmly with apes in Jurassic
Park with 67%
what the argument was hard versus fast
and furious got 18% and apes and back to
the future got 13% I want to go ahead
and say right now I will see all of
those as soon as you guys started
talking okay I can't do this Thank You
Danielle and yes I would see all of
those movies except for the one Scott
okay something Crazy's happened we're
time all right so here is the question
you're gonna pick a movie out of this
[Laughter]
wannabe rap all right question is this
is a king
what's so don't know your answer until
we come to you what is the everybody
look at you can't look at it though what
is the best Jurassic Park sequel what is
the best Jurassic Park sequel all right
everybody got one everybody got one so
you will each have 20 seconds we're
gonna start with Scott you will each
have 20 seconds to defend why the movie
you got is the best Jurassic Park sequel
Scott man here we go the reason why 1997
so lost no it's the best sequel for
Jurassic Park it's because of the t-rex
in San Diego that was so cool to see a
t-rex on the mainland to see t-rex
really crying all right Emma see I'm
gonna go ahead and argue that the best
Jurassic Park sequel is Jurassic world
because it was a reintroduction of the
franchise it was Jurassic world for a
new era you have a great young star in
Chris Pratt you have the heightened
reality of the dinosaurs that are now
even more man-made and enhanced and on
top of that again you you are
introducing Jurassic Park to a new
generation of people and you're like you
know what those old movies happen but
now we're gonna do it again
I'm alright DJ I'm gonna argue the
Jurassic Park 3 is the best part because
seeing noobs back as an art film and
also they're back on the island the
island that we love and they introduce
new interesting dinosaurs that don't
need to be genetically engineered to be
interesting like the Spinosaurus and it
was a fun action-packed film about the
idea being stuck on that island along
which is what we love about the first
Jurassic Park alright time okay so the
way this will work worst answer is going
to be eliminated worst answer will be
eliminated
let's start with Danielle Danielle go
ahead and pick the worst you are the
worst these arguments were as good as
y'all I have to say dinosaurs on the
mainland I didn't feel was argued well
enough I am sorry Scott okay that's man
I've won against Scott by the way if we
all tide and pick one person don't have
an extra tiebreaker so the sugar Dan I
must concur with my fellow Dan agree or
disagree I felt both DJ and Emma had
many varying reasons for why their
sequels were superior and I only heard
one thing from Scott which was that
there was a t-rex on the mainland dinos
on the mainland which was not quite
enough to overwhelm the other two so I
also have to go with DJ Emma at do
eliminates Scott manse thanks for
shopping
I should have said Spielberg Scott the
landslide brought you down like the
Smashing Pumpkins cover okay so go into
the speed round it's going to be DJ
verse Emma real quick before we jump
right into the speed round I just want
to thank everybody who was here everyone
who put it together
last week's movie fights women in film
events everyone behind the scenes here
at screen junkies everyone from around
the internet and all of our friends that
came and you who clicked in and who
donated and brought us so much goodwill
and money for a great cause and if you
are a donor and submitted a question we
are going to start using your movie
fights questions next week thank you I
salute you alright let's jump into this
round I'm gonna be honest I think I was
gonna make now it's anybody's game okay
so again you are tied 1-1 the first
player to reach four points wins I will
ask a question first person to speak
will then have the chance to answer
first 20 seconds 20 seconds and then 10
seconds 10 seconds as far as rebuttals
Danielle will be chiming in with her own
opinions no longer being the conduit of
the people because they're just in time
and the speed round we love you down
yeah true dat ok here is the first
question of the speed round best movie
featuring Melissa McCarthy and any role
bridesmaids oh no they're not are they
both your bridesmaids I can't remember
best movie featuring Melissa McCarthy
any role I was like who's Annie role I'm
gonna bridesmaid ok
five all right we got bridesmaids and
spy Emma you spoke first so 20 seconds
begins when you speak now listen this is
the thing is yes Melissa McCarthy has
had a lot of really fabulous film roles
but the role that really introduced her
and established her as a powerhouse
player in the world of comedy was the
movie bridesmaids in it we see a
character who is incredibly human and
flawed and just happy with who she is
she makes no apologies about who she has
that scene where she takes all the
puppies it's priceless list because
let's be real if you showed up to a
bridal shower full of puppies you would
want to take all those puppies I'm all
right
EJ bridesmaids woes are coming out but I
think her best film has to be spy
because not only is it a great role for
her that really plays up her talent for
physical comedy but it is a great
Lampoon of a genre that we've seen
before
and a cool take on with a protagonist
that we don't normally see in most
McCarthy that really plays up her skills
and abilities in a perfect way time all
right
rebuttal listen I agree that spy is a
fantastic film but if you're talking
about things that are lampooning a genre
we see that in bridesmaids bridesmaids
is just lampooning that male buddy
comedy kind of genre and without Melissa
McCarthy the movies simply doesn't work
bridesmaid is an ensemble she's a good
part of it but she's not the only one
there's Kristen Wiig there's a bunch of
other actresses in there that are great
spy is solely focused on her and her
ability in fact Jason Statham is her
sporting man it is her movie time okay
good stuff choices here let's start damn
Earl very good arguments on both sides
but I have to say ultimately DJ's more
for this boom one for DJ Danielle
Radford I have to agree as much as I
would want to take those puppies I don't
have the difference between a starring
role and an ensemble was on somebody was
really what got me so I got to go with
an image DJ you got to the point it's
2-1 DJ said bridesmaids it immediately
might know I wish I pick spy I haven't
seen spy but you know what
Herts great you know if you would have
said that Melissa McCarthy was nominated
for an Oscar for bridesmaids it would
have had it perhaps the question was
best movie featuring that McCarthy not
best melissa mccarthy movie there let us
move on question number two of speed
around with George Carlin sadly gone
what stand-up comedian should be the new
Rufus and Bill and Ted 300 what stand-up
comedian should be the new Rufus and
Bill and Ted 300 white pink ah I'm gonna
say I know okay I'll say Aziz Ansari
okay the stand-up comedians I used to
follow or not found out recently or not
good because he's done stand-up oh okay
Aziz versus Glover and when you spoke
first yeah listen I know there's a
little controversy there there's no room
for nuance in this world anymore what
can I say and I understand but this Isan
sorry I mean if you look at the is track
record as a character performer so much
of particularly Aniston things like
Parks and Recreation really created this
this character that you believe is kind
of this like sniveling little sidekick
kind of character and it's it's a it's a
kind of role that Aziz Ansari is
incredibly capable of carrying off we've
seen in Atlanta that Don Weber has huge
range as a comedic performer and he's
able to disappear into a roll and
anytime you can give him something
outside of the box if you've seen Teddy
Perkins on Atlanta it becomes a
completely different character
unrecognizable and I think he would
really excel in a role like this that
allows him to play something completely
different than we're used to him him
doing but I feel like some of what we
would be looking for is a character that
is really going to bring a lot of their
own personal style to it which isn't to
say that Donald Glover doesn't have his
but as you say he is somebody that
really melds into a role as I think that
Aziz Ansari would really make this roles
own Don Weber is a creative force and he
could be able to add something really
interesting and dynamic to and also keep
people to make a dope song to go with
the movie which would be a great
addition that even George Carlin was not
able to provide time all right Wow
interesting answers here by the way the
correct answer would have been Dave
Chappelle
I would assign Amy Schumer perhaps but
based on these choices and these
arguments I got to go with Emma on this
one her rebuttal really sold me with the
personal style that disease has whereas
you know Donald Glover he could do a lot
of stuff and he often like he doesn't do
any wrong but I think she swayed me with
his ease let's go to Danielle Radford um
I have to agree with you in that what
really sold it for me was when he said
that Glover is a creative force and
could make a song those are both true
it's not the job of an actor to be
creative or to make a song it's to make
choices it's not to actually like make
the movie and then so when she said own
personal style and make it his own to me
that's a little bit more BAM
okay Emma you got the point line up at
to choke dissenting opinion okay noted
for the record too - this is good one
all right question numero tres by the
way I want to see other people's answers
to that comedian question before yeah
that's a fun one okay number three
what's the best Guy Ritchie movie walk
talk Lock Stock and Two Smoking Barrels
lock stock from DJ oh god I cannot think
of any Guy Ritchie I need somebody to
help me out I cannot think of any
Sherlock oh yeah I'll do shall go
Sherlock very generous of DJ to help his
opponent my brain is that was a great
great moment and sportsmanship okay I
was I was there trying to come up with I
would have said the movie starring
Madonna that he directed okay
rock and roll no okay DJ you spoke first
for Lock Stock and Two Smoking Barrels
I believe Dan will correct me if I'm
wrong I believe that was his first movie
that was kind of his coming out party
and like a lot of directors with a
intense style that is kind of the
patient zero the kind of the best
reflection of what he does well it was
also kind of a coming-out for Jason
Statham and a great use of his skills
and his showcase of him not just as an
action performer but as a great actor
and Guy Ritchie brought that out of him
okay I would argue that Sherlock
actually is guy ritchie's most the best
movie because it shows his ability to
adapt a source material that was
potentially stale and do it justice
while without completely straying from
and I expected Sherlock to come in it
was going to be this big action
adventure fancy Locke was still very
much the same sort of neurotic
obsessive-compulsive kind of character
that we know him to be from Sir Arthur
Conan Doyle Guy Ritchie's a director
that's kind of developed becoming more
style over substance lock stock as a
great example of a combination of style
and substance the style that was there
in the future is there but there's also
a core solid crime movie so yeah I
disagree I disagree and in Sherlock
Holmes you get plenty of substance
because he is drawing from this source
material that has a whole bunch of
substance and he makes it serve a film
that was still very much his own vision
and not simply just a rehash of what was
written in Arthur Conan Doyle time time
time time time and a little extra time
okay because I keep trying to say Sir
Arthur Conan Doyle okay sure thing okay
let's go to Dan Merle I DJ I believe
made the more compelling case the not
only in genre but in style and substance
and cast I think that DJ made the better
argument and I give him a little extra
bonus point for for being a selfless
generous compete absolutely rarely seen
in these I was kids yeah
1:01 Oh DJ Danielle you're going with me
next oh yes I am
I hate this I keep going a second and
agreeing with the person who said first
but I have to go DJ on this one what
really got me is scientists and
substance crime movie and his arguments
were really about why this was Guy
Ritchie's movie and it was a good
gravity movie I loved her arguments but
when it came down to him being able to
adapt source material that doesn't
really it's not really all of like a Guy
Ritchie movies a chance Thank You
Danielle okay it is three to DJ if DJ
takes this point he wins
Emma you need it to time you need it to
tie question number four the speed
around what's Peter Jackson's best movie
that's not set in middle-earth King Kong
Peter Jackson's best movie not set in
middle-earth
I'm real bad at who directed what movie
guys this is what I don't compete in the
Schmo down is because I'm really
terrible god fine I what's that the the
freakin puppet movie he did they like
meet the Feebles yep let's do meet the
Feebles okay we have King Kong versus
meet the Feebles and DJ spoke first 20
seconds again when you speak now
King Kong represents Peter Jackson at
the height of his power he's coming
right out of Laurel rings and he takes
all the lessons he learned from that and
takes an all-time film classic and is
able to make his spin on it and again
always a challenge making you care about
Kong and the people around him as well
and makes a sweeping epic interesting
engaging movie that is can't stand
alongside the original disagree King
Kong is a video game half of the movie
is just watching CGI monkeys fight CGI
dinosaurs you want some real deal watch
meet the Feebles it is an effed up
puppet movie like if you ever wanted to
see like the muppet it's a very bold
choice it's basically taking like Muppet
type characters and putting them in this
really real gritty real world situation
you've got hookers you've got Muppets
doing drugs it is and ultimately it's
all prat times
meet the Feebles is a big old splatter
fest it's him just having fun which is
great but it's not him being able to
layer his characters layer his story the
effects he's able to do with whetted
that he was able to do Lord the rings
that show up in Kong yeah you're seeing
what Peter Jackson can do with money
meet the peoples is what Peter Jackson
can do without money that is what got
him the job to do Lord of the Rings it
was certainly a big component of it
without it Peter Jackson wouldn't be the
filmmaker he is today
boom alright yeah Emma I thought you
slayed that one I can point to Emma Dan
Emma you have you have tied it up this
is a great moment in sports this is for
the game okay final question who should
replace Billy Bob Thornton and kya and
Kyle Chandler as the as the new Friday
Night Lights coach who should replace
Milligan Thornton and Kyle Chandler the
new Friday Night Lights coach
I will go Bradley Whitford Melo
Ventimiglia from this is us I probably
said his name wrong that's why specify
Jeremy Lowe from this is awesome heroes
versus Bradley Whitford the West Wing
okay Emma you're up first so Bradley
Whitford is a character who is a person
who we've seen have an incredible career
in television he has this incredible
ability to bring this real depth to a
character and with the character like
the coach in Friday Night Lights you
need somebody who can be both a hard-ass
and yet had that underlying softness to
them and really be a dad that is
multifaceted much like we saw a little
bit in get out where you really believed
that he was this good person I am time
the Bell means stop
the coach of Friday Night Lights is
supposed to be everybody's dad and Milo
has emphasized that in this is us he's
become everybody's dad in that show and
he's able to take that skill set to this
and he can also be a hard-ass because he
was able to play those layers in Heroes
as well about being a tougher character
but it's really those dad chops that he
showed in this is us that I think would
translate really well to a Friday night
like Milo Ventimiglia has been pushed
into that role by this as us I would
argue that it's this is less writers
that have made him do that whereas
Bradley Whitford we he is a track record
of being a being dad characters of being
in charge of his roles on time Wow
okay how about it if I've already won oh
yeah Bradley Whitford Bradley Whitford
has done a series of his roles but I
don't think he is the iconic he kind of
disappears into the movies he's in he's
never really a standout whereas Milo
he's one of the stars of this show he's
one people are talking about time all
right DJ had it for me with his initial
Milo argument and it wasn't overcome by
Emma so I go one for DJ Danielle this
was really difficult because I could
easily see either of these guys in this
role I would say that what pushed me
over to Emma's was when she mentioned
that Milo it's really it's the writing
and so we don't know if that's gonna be
something you can carry over if it isn't
the same team of writers so I have to go
with Emma we're locked at one one Dan
Burrell you decide the whole ball of wax
is the writing for Bradley Whitford
to write and I and they even mentioned
that in her argument that the importance
of being a coach is everyone's dad and
then that was the entire crux of DJ's
argument so I feel like DJ kind of used
Emma's point and doubled down on it I
have to go DJ DJ
[Applause]
your answer was good enough to take the
point you caught up
yeah overcame the odds on DJ talk to us
tell us about yeah you're plugging
something early in the middle of around
listen weird that jte had that on deck
for yeah listen if you like my pitch of
Planet Apes meets Jurassic Park I'll
give you something even better what if
zombies had to fight with giant
dinosaurs science gone wrong if you're
worried about the humanity like the
argument we have three primary
characters that have struggled they're
very human once a recent mom and it's
just I wanted to make a comic book this
is my comic book chaos theory comic calm
and I wanted to put everything I've ever
wanted to see in a comic book into my
own book and you can find it all here so
it's not only zombies and dinosaurs but
there's aliens every issues 5 issues 100
pages every issue is like its own
big-budget blockbuster film that you
would probably hear argued on this set
and for screen junkies Watchers if you
go and you contribute $25 or up because
that's where you get a physical thing
that I send to you I'll throw it and you
say you can go to the comments section
on the Kickstarter page and say hey I'm
from screen junkies I will throw in a
postcard map of the United States in
this world because there's a ton of
backstory I wasn't able to fit in the
comic and the United States has gone
through a lot in this in this world if
you saw the picture up there Florida's
not quite there anymore California all
of its own so it's not if you're excited
about zombies and dinosaurs I've got all
that but it's got aliens it's got action
it's got adventure it's got heart it's
it's there's something about to defeat
everybody
you know if you're being a back to the
future I got something area
are there any mech suits in there yeah I
got something for you okay and
surprisingly and what works at all at
all kind of one idea feeds into another
wasn't just me jamming stuff together
all because the original idea that
occurred to me is at the end of the Zack
Snyder gone the Dead remake huh you they
sail to an uncharted island my brain was
like well what if that was the dress
park island whoa
and I was like that's silly but the more
I thought about it's like it's actually
kind of badass cool that's awesome
and go ahead and plug your podcast as
well only stupid answers you can only go
to only stupid answers calm we just had
our 100th episode we did a big live
event for it so rats will be the live
event it's me and Sam basher and also
Steve Zaragoza and Mike Falzone from
dynamic banjo want Garrett and Roxy
stryer who you know from TV fights with
us so Monday is our 100th episode so
check that out and you can find it only
stupid answers calm and that has all the
places you can listen on all social
media
nicely done and your comic sounds
awesome and congrats on the victory
brother Scott man Scott man don't plug
something you want to digest regale us
with something let's just follow me on
Twitter at movie manse actually if you
if you go to fathom events things yeah
yeah I actually introduced all the last
time I went to one always always a
pleasure to have you here right yeah you
really brought it you came no and
Danielle was on my side in the end so
you know what and I consider it a
gracious last in DJ did help me out so I
don't think fair that he won um tell us
where to find you I can be found all
over the internet wherever Emma pipes
are sold my name Emma Fife EMM AF y FF
II I'm doing all kinds of stuff yeah you
can see me on the Motown calling matches
managing the best faction in the league
go Fight Club I also can be found every
Wednesday over on twitch.tv slash hyper
RPG that is hyper RPG on Twitch 8
o'clock p.m. doing pencils and parsecs
which is a Star Wars are
gee it's crazy our last episode was a
real like mashup of Star Wars meets
aliens and also kind of Resident Evil it
was freaking awesome you guys should
totally check it out good times thanks
Emma
good work Dan Merle how much Scott mance
knows about Star Trek huh I saw one of
these fathom events things he was
there's a video interview with William
Shatner and shan'er tells a story about
the making of Star Trek 2 that Scott
then corrects him and says like no that
was doing the making of a Star Trek
Captain Kirk that's how much Scott mance
knows it's awesome yeah here I'm here
all right
Twitter always great to have you holding
it down and keeping us factually
accurate
Danielle Radford Oh as per years you can
find me at Danielle Radford wherever you
get your social medias on Instagram I am
Danielle underscore Radford I'm just
trying to get to that 10 K so I can
start getting those fat girls
sponsorships I need some clothes I need
some tights
I need more dresses help a girl out
follow dangun on insta I went to space a
that thing yesterday and you can see
some BTS in the space yesterday I would
space yesterday I got to play astronaut
he's really cool but more about that on
your social medias yeah yeah hit me up
on my social medias at how Rudnick
Twitter Instagram thank you for watching
and please tune in next week we're gonna
start using those donors questions
thanks again for everybody with women in
film and thanks for other good time
strength and Billy biz jte and Joe star
your giggle in the background always is
the
like Mike